Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new video for all the crazy huge changes at
dc movies and tv shows that were just announced
this past week the new ceo of the company after
their big merger made these announcements about
how they're basically going to change everything
that's happening at dc so i'll explain what's
going on they're also appointing a new kevin feige
type of figure at dc everybody keeps saying that
dc is getting its own version of a kevin feige
you're late you it's a huge deal it's all good
news so it's no reason to worry or anything like
that i'll explain what's going on if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos most of you saw this past week that warner
brothers finished their big merger with discovery
it was this huge merger between a couple mega
companies dc is owned by warner brothers so when
we talk about dc movies tv shows the comics all
that stuff is owned by warner brothers even though
this video is all about what's happening with
the justice league the flash black adams superman
batman all the rest of their characters this is
all still warner brothers specific stuff dc is
inside warner brothers so all the people who used
to work at warner brothers before they just got
fired basically called a lot of the shots about
the movies the tv shows that they made at dc quick
history what had happened in the past couple years
is that a big tech company a t basically bought
warner brothers out bought an entire studio to get
all the content they made a big streaming service
called hbo max it was really confusing they took
on way too much debt like many many billions of
dollars to buy this giant studio worth of content
not just buying dc because warner brothers owns
many different film brands att got cold feet and
said we took on way too much debt this is hurting
our tech business so they sold off the studio
and they merged with discovery channel networks
so warner brothers is basically back to where they
used to be just being a regular film and tv studio
all the people that worked there seemed like they
were way more happy with the way they're running
things at this new company than they were under
at t so it sounds like a relatively good thing
because all these companies got bought and sold
so many times a bunch of the people that used
to be in charge warner bros especially the people
that everyone really hated online you saw people
yelling about most of them got fired and now the
ceo of this brand new entire company called warner
brothers discovery the person who tells everyone
what to do was recently talking to variety about
what their long-term plans are for dc he said
everything about the way they're doing business
is changing in a big way all the changes make
a ton of sense and you'll be wondering why they
didn't do this a billion years ago like we've
been yelling about this the whole time how come
they didn't do this a long time ago what he said
is that they're turning dc into its own vertical
at this new mega company so dc is gonna have a
much bigger say in the films the movies in the
comics than they did before remember previously
what happened is that warner brothers typically
picked and choose what kind of tv shows they would
make not dc and what they were going to do as part
of this is make someone the new kevin feige of
dc so a lot of you understand a little bit about
what kevin feige does at marvel everybody
thinks of marvel they think of kevin feige
a couple years ago what disney did with marvel
is that they basically took all the different
things that marvel does all the tv shows all the
movies all the comics all the toys everything
and they just put kevin feige in charge of
everything previously different groups in
the company were in charge of different types of
business so previously kevin feige just ran marvel
studios they just made the movies the people that
made the marvel television shows like the marvel
netflix shows that was a completely different
group of people the people in charge of the toys
were different the people in charge of the marvel
comics were completely different group of people
disney simplified all that and just made
kevin feige creatively in charge of everything
that was right before they started doing all the
marvel disney plush shows and started rolling out
disney plus it all kind of makes sense now makes
somebody in charge of everything so that it's way
more consistent across all the movies and tv shows
he didn't really change much about what they're
doing with the comic books and i think that's
going to be the same for dc like the person who
is in charge of dc won't mess a ton with what's
happening with the comics this is mostly a video
about the movies and the tv shows what changed
at marvel with all the tv shows they were doing
is that they started doing the marvel studios
disney plus shows marvel studios branding the
marvel studios logo started playing in front of
everything and you started to see all the movie
actors that kevin feige had been working with
for so many years showing up in the tv shows
in the brand new characters like for instance
the moon knight show that i'm doing videos for
they introduce those brand new characters brand
new mythology that's all intended to cross over
with the future movies so there's way more
synergy between the movies and the tv shows
dc is slowly starting to do that
like they announced all these batman
spin-off tv shows from robert
pattinson and matt reeves batman movie
they have an hbo penguin show with colin farrell's
version of the penguin that's going to explain his
backstory and deal more with what's happening
him in the future there's that arkham asylum tv
show that might feature a version of the riddler
and the joker that we saw during the batman movie
there's the green lantern core hbo show that
they're working on right now that's supposed to
come out next year just imagine dc doing way way
more of that kind of stuff what this brand new ceo
of the mega company said is that whoever becomes
the new kevin feige of dc is supposed to be making
way way more big budget hbo shows for characters
and way more movies also way more of them about
the non-holy trinity of characters so like
we always make jokes about how thirsty warner
brothers is for batman projects like we have at
least three different giant live-action versions
of batman there are way more versions of batman
that are coming but there are three really big
ones coming to the screen in the next couple
of years between robert pattinson's batman ben
affleck's batman and then michael keaton's batman
when the ceo said that they have lots of plans
for way more smaller movies with lots of spin-off
characters he specifically called out the joaquin
phoenix joker movie of an example of a movie that
didn't cost quite as much as your traditional big
movies and featured characters that you wouldn't
necessarily expect would normally get their own
movies the difference with the joaquin phoenix
joker movie is that was more of like a dc black
label movie this new announcement doesn't
mean they're just doing a bunch more black
label movies it just means they're doing a bunch
more movies that aren't necessarily going to be
giant giant movies with the a-list characters
like there are a ton of dc characters who aren't
necessarily part of the justice league who would
make for amazing tv shows even amazing movies that
you don't have to spend 150 million dollars on
and it's a lot easier for dc to jump around in the
spectrum of how hardcore each of these movies are
like they can do their smaller rated r movies they
can do big budget pg-13 movies like traditional
superhero films when people talk about animation
dc animation has been killing it for a long long
time batman the animated series is probably one of
the best tv series of all time not just animated
series any kind of tv series batman mask of the
phantasm also one of the best batman movies of all
time it just happens to be animated during this
big discussion the ceo said that they also have
big plans to revitalize their superman character
all you superman stands will love this he said
that they had vastly underutilized superman as
a character the past several years like he's
one of our biggest characters why aren't we
doing anything with them right now when the ceo
says something like that you know they have big
plans for superman in the future a lot of you know
asking does this mean henry cavill would ever come
back would they make man of steel 2 would they
actually have him cross over with black adam
like they've been talking about other justice
league characters there's been a lot of talk
about him crossing over with some of these other
movies even if he doesn't get his own solo film
are they going to keep making the alternate
universe superman movies that they talked
about the past couple years like the val zod
hbo show with michael b jordan that's a tv show
regardless i think that henry cavill's chances
of actually coming back just shot way way up and
that's probably part of the reason why he's
been so quiet about all the superman stuff
the past year so so what does this all mean
and who's going to be dc's new kevin feige
lots of people have been throwing names around
and asking if this means zack snyder is going to
come back and do more movies and hbo shows inside
his own snyder verse like we just got the justice
league snyder cut last year it was light years
better than the theatrical cut he had all these
plans for sequel movies i did a video about that
so i'll link it below in the description he did
have fully planned justice league 2 justice league
3 and then a bunch of other spin-offs as well
now that dc sounds like it's ramping up on a
billion more hbo shows and movies and firing a
lot of the people who used to be in charge of dc
who zack snyder didn't necessarily get along with
it's definitely more possible that zack snyder
gets asked to do some more dc projects like i said
all the dc shows that you heard about the past few
years like the matt reeves batman spin-off shows
with all those movie actors the green lantern
chorus show all the other stuff that they've been
developing that stuff is all still happening the
movies that they've been in the middle of making
are all still coming out one of the only things
that will probably change noticeably is that dc
will get their new kevin feige person in charge
of everything and you'll see way more big budget
shows that have connections to the movies way more
of the movie actors showing up in the hbo shows
that was part of the thing with them bringing
back michael keaton's batman in the flash movie
initially because they wanted to set up way more
crossovers with a version of batman that's also
part of the reason for them getting into all the
multiverse of it all is that they can pick and
choose which versions they use and they can switch
actors if they need to like if people don't want
to continue or if they do have really big problems
with the people they're working with right now
there are only a few people in hollywood who are
probably qualified for what dc needs like whoever
becomes their new kevin feige will have to be
an excellent producer of movies and tv shows
a really really good business person who knows
how to run a massive company and they'll have to
have an understanding of who all these characters
are in the comics that they originally come from
there are a lot of good producers out there there
are a lot of good business people out there but
there aren't a ton of people who can do all of
those different things at the same time and happen
to be comic book nerds so everyone let me know
in the comments who do you want to be dc's new
kevin feige i will say it's definitely not going
to be kevin feige he already said a long time ago
he has no plans of leaving marvel anytime soon
in what new movies and tv shows do you want dc
to start making that they're not already making
right now everyone can start their campaign for
terry mcginnis and michael keaton batman beyond
hbo show right here but i've got a couple new
trailers and bonus videos that i'm working on
right now those will post in the next few days
make sure you enable alerts for my channel to be
the first to watch those and everyone click here
for my moon knight episode 4 trailer video and
click here for my full moon knight episode 3 video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!